the fight for Tripoli is escalating now
the foreign ministry is calling on the
United Nations and the International
Criminal Court to intervene the UN
recognized the government accuses forces
fighting for warlord halifa Hefner of
committing crimes against humanity and
their campaign to capture the capital we
are asking the international community
to perform its role after doesn't have
any legitimacy and has been destroying
Tripoli for the past eight months yet
the international community has not
moved to stop him only now as we have a
new ally and regional and international
powers are rising against us the war on
the southern outskirts of Tripoli has
cost the lives of hundreds of civilians
and wounded many more after the forces
repeatedly targeted residential areas
and government-run facility x' with
airstrikes and rockets nearly 140,000
Libyans have fled their homes to seek
safety also under threat our oil
revenues which are the backbone of
Libya's economy the National Oil
Corporation is assessing the damage
following recent airstrikes on the oil
refinery in the western city of Zaire
and as government forces battle to stop
the fall of Tripoli after forces are
reported to be getting reinforcements
from Russian mercenaries an advanced it
weapons supplied by the United Arab
Emirates Turkish troops could soon be
joining the conflict the promised
Turkish support for forces loyal to do
and recognize the government is being
seen by some as crucial to preventing
the fall of Tripoli Turkey's president
says Parliament will vote next month on
a Monday to send troops but as Hefner's
forces advance further into the southern
neighborhoods and closer to densely
populated areas of the capital the field
of human casualties is growing Mahmoud
Abdul Wahid al Jazeera Tripoli